[MUSIC PLAYING]
The 2023 NHL Global Series.
We got this, baby.
That's it.
Yes!
Yes, boy!
[SINGING]
Score!
Mid air.
Oh, my god.
A brilliant week in Stockholm.
This guy runs this city, man.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
To have a trip like this and
spend some time together,
I'm pretty excited.
It'll be an awesome week to
travel overseas and just hang
out with the team and
play games and have fun.
Woo!
You guys feeling nice in Sweden.
It's very cool playing
over here in general,
and we had a good practice.
We have to build each other
up and push each other
to work hard and have
fun at the same time.
I get a lot of family and
friends coming for the game,
too.
It's really exciting.
It's fun to come
home to my country
here and play a couple of
games in front Swedish fans
and play in front of
family and friends.
It's going to be
a fun experience.
Yes.
That was nice.
That was real nice.
It's been a dream to
come back here and play.
I didn't think that would
happen in my career,
to play an NHL game
in Sweden, so that's
going to be very special.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Welcome to Avicii Arena
in Stockholm, Sweden,
for the 2023 NHL
Global Series Sweden
featuring the Detroit Red
Wings and the Ottawa Senators.
Remember we got back into our
process before our last game.
Our compete was
through the roof.
We were at a high
level, and we're going
to need it again to start here.
We got Alfie,
special guest here.
Going to come on the bench.
Going to get the
lineup here tonight.
Come on up.
Hey!
Thanks, guys.
It's an honor Thank TJ for
giving me this opportunity.
Today, we have Korpi
starting in that.
Subi, Sandy, Joe, Timmy,
and B. Good start.
Early.
Everybody, get going.
Have some fun.
Come on, Ray.
Hey, maybe a shot
off the backboards.
And Dylan Larkin, in career game
600, faces off against Clyde,
and we're underway.
That's the way to skate.
Go, go, go, go, go.
Come on, Chick.
Hey, make sure we're
pushing the pace, boys.
Just exploded from shoots.
Makes a stop.
Rebound, score.
Yeah!
Let's go, baby.
Let's go, Bobby.
Let's go, man.
Jumps back, goes down, gets back
up again, sends it in front.
Tkachuk scores!
Second of the night
for Brady Tkachuk.
That was a six Sally two.
Oh my God.
Got a little push here.
Just win some shifts, boys.
Just win some shifts here.
Oh!
Let's go!
We got to push
back a little bit.
These guys are leaning on us.
Scores!
Yes!
Sanderson makes it 3-0 Ottowa.
Let's go, baby.
Don't sacrifice
it the other way.
Make sure we get above.
It'll come.
Put them in!
That's it.
Skate!
Line drive.
Drake, drive.
In comes for Joseph Knockanure.
Shoots, scores!
Yeah!
Singles throwing around.
It's a 4-0 lead.
Great shift, boys.
Oh!
Hey, hey!
Stay on it.
Now the wing's breaking up a
play, and they got a 2 on 1.
Lucas Reymond in with a shot.
He scores!
Yes!
Yes, boys!
Let's go!
We earned that one, boys.
We earned that one.
Shoots.
Score!
Yeah!
Come on!
Let's go.
Let's [MUTED] go!
Let's go!
Nobody knew where it was,
and it bounces into the net.
And suddenly, it's
a 4-2 hockey game.
Go, go!
Lifted to the neutral zone.
Detroit with it there.
Right back in.
Compher will play
now to Gostisbehere.
Cross in front scores!
Yeah!
And the Red Wings are
suddenly within 1.
What a pass that was
across to Alex DeBrincat.
We got to get hungry, boys.
Get on our toes.
Here's a defenseman volly.
Gostisbehere in front.
The pass, and they score!
And the Red Wings
have tied it up.
Yeah!
And a 4-0 advantage
for Ottawa is gone.
Yeah, goals!
Yeah, let's go!
Let's go!
Work hard, have some fun.
Here we go, Johnny.
Here we go, man.
Hey, stay back!
Hey!
Hey, hold on!
You see it right here?
OK, here we go, men.
Oh [MUTED],, that
was a good drop.
Push, push!
Man on man!
That's it, Brady.
Take it to the cage!
We got to get going fast.
You guys got 40 seconds.
If not, you're off.
Let's go.
Hey!
Good shift.
And the teams will go
to overtime tied at 4.
Let's go, boys.
Hey, guys.
We got to start
clogging them a bit.
30 seconds!
30!
Let's win battles, boys.
Come on, come on!
Work, boys!
Go get it.
Time winding down in overtime.
Puck is picked up.
Here's a chance.
Tries to send it in front.
Bouncing back.
Scores!
Out of midair.
Yeah!
Tim Stutzle.
Let's go, baby!
[YELLS]
Oh my God.
Oh my God
Two seconds remaining
in overtime.
What a huge extra point
for the Ottawa Senators.
I think it's pretty lucky.
I knew we don't have a
lot of time there left,
and I just tried
to get on the net.
And I think the goalie didn't
really see that coming.
Way to find a way to
win that one, boys.
Corky, I thought you were great.
A couple of goals, but
Timmy with the home run.
Here we go!
Go, go, go, go!
Heads up!
Let's play.
Yeah!
They score!
[YELLS]
Something big is coming.
Our connections here in Sweden
for the Maple Leafs are deep.
A Leaf legend, Hall
of Famer, captain,
and all-time leading
scorer Mats Sundin.
[APPLAUSE]
Game two of this
NHL global series.
These are the two most
popular NHL teams in Sweden--
Detroit for a younger
generation, Nick Lidstrom
and company, and for the older
generation, the Maple Leafs,
Saporia Solving and Mats Sundin.
Samsonov, Inet, Riley, Larsson,
Nylander, Jarnkrok, and Domi,
boys.
Let's go!
Make us proud, guys.
Have a great game.
Here we go.
Let's go, boys!
Ready.
Ready, boys?
Here we go!
Get up there!
That's it.
All four Swedes
for the two teams
are in the starting lineup
and Lucas Reymond for Detroit.
Jarnkrok, and
Nylander for Toronto.
Go, go, go!
Heads up!
Save.
Wink going to get it.
They walk in front Oh,
what a save by Samsonov!
You had a good save, dude.
Nine.
[BLOWS WHISTLE]
Hey!
We're done!
Let it go.
Run, run.
We're not coming from behind.
Run, we're not
coming from behind.
And time expires here.
After the opening 20
minutes, Toronto and Detroit
scoreless after one.
Fly with the puck here.
Let's get ourselves
into the game mode.
Like you're going to be
ahead of me, way ahead of me,
or I'm going to try to
go through the stick.
OK.
Matthews by Sprong.
Breaks it free.
With a chance.
down.
The puck's still loose.
They jam away at it.
[YELLING]
He wants a penalty shot.
There's a penalty shot
awarded to Detroit
as the Toronto player covers
the puck in the goal crease.
And it's going to
be Daniel Sprong.
Has to be somebody who was on
the ice, and here he comes.
Top of the circles, middle
of the ice, now with Adik,
and scores.
Yeah!
Woo hoo hoo!
Let's go!
Come on, boys.
Let's play in their end.
Detroit kind of asserting their
dominance in the second period.
Shot!
Yeah!
Lucas Reymond with a shot.
Yeah, boys!
And the Wings have
a 2 to 0 lead.
Ready, boys?
Here we go!
Guys, attack the net.
Attack the net.
Oh, much better pace.
Much better presence at the net.
Johnny!
Taveras feeds that back.
Nylander gathers it back up.
What a move by Nylander.
Winds in, waits, feeds it.
They score!
Taps it home.
Play ball.
[CHEERING]
Hey, we're good, boys.
We're good.
Let's get it back.
Let's go!
Looking for Taveras Nylander's
in front of the net,
and he scores!
Whoa!
Yes, Willy!
Come on!
And a tie game
here in Stockholm.
And his grandmother
watching him play
for the first time with a very
subdued Swedish celebration.
Mitchell, great pass.
Wear these guys down here.
Wear them down the
rest of the way.
Go, go, go, go!
Heads up!
Leafs win the face off, send
it around back of the net.
Bertuzzi comes up with it.
Now in the back, out in front.
Taveras scores!
What a play!
Holy Mackinac, the Leafs
have come all the way back
and taken the lead.
In a game where there was
nothing going on for Toronto
through two periods, they're now
leading with five minutes left.
Scramble draw.
Heads up!
Back in front.
Hey!
Oh my god.
Plays it back for Seider.
Shoots.
That was blocked in front.
And Riley plays it out.
It's going to be cleared.
The Leafs are going to win it.
And the horn will signal a
dramatic come from behind win
in Stockholm left by the Super
Swede himself William Nylander.
It's a hell of a job
to come back and get
those points, fellas.
We talked about overwhelming
them with our pace.
But to me, I know we
lose the second period,
but we're set up
through the game.
A, Sammy making some big saves
for us and a huge power play
goal.
Yeah!
Let's go.
Something big is coming.
Here we go from Stockholm.
He scores!
We got this, baby.
Boys.
Reach and scores!
Swede against Swede.
Something big is coming.
A beautiful fall afternoon
in Stockholm, Sweden.
Minnesota Wild take on
the Ottawa Senators.
Let's go.
Come on, Jimmy Smits!
Let's go!
Please welcome back to Sweden
Ottawa Senators legend Daniel
Alfredsson!
Alfie!
And now Daniel
Alfredsson will walk
straight from the
ceremonial face
off right to the Ottawa bench.
All the icing.
We got this, baby.
It's time to drop the puck.
And here we go from Stockholm.
Here's a chance for
Tkachuk coming in
and a save by Gustavsson.
[YELLS]
Ow, ow, ow!
Ow!
Nice.
Simple plays here.
Stoops look.
Fires.
Save Gustavsson.
Closer down the zone, hey?
We got to make some
[MUTED] plays down there.
Time expires here in
the opening period.
Ottawa and Minnesota
scoreless through one.
Underway in the second period.
Walk through the slot.
Fired one that came off
the end glass, and Branson
with his glove covered the puck.
That's going to
be a penalty shot.
Minnesota has been
awarded a penalty shot
for an Ottawa player closing his
hand on the puck in the crease.
Johansson in all alone.
Johansson with a
forehand, backhand.
Save is made by Forsberg.
Rossi's up.
Slot that's picked
up by Zuccarello.
Cuts to the point.
Faber, a shot.
They score!
It may have been tipped
in front by Rossi.
And the Wild had the game's
first tally here in Stockholm.
It's 1-0 Minnesota.
[CHANTING]
Minnesota Wild have a
lead after two periods.
Middle, middle, middle!
Good hit.
Smack that [MUTED] every time.
First time.
We're going to get one there.
Here's a breakaway chance.
Busting in, Cranston
with a shot.
Scores!
Cranston a breakaway blast.
A pass from the goalie.
So, Swede to Swede to
the back of the net.
And the pride of Sweden,
ties the game at 1.
Come on, boys.
That a boy!
Minnesota penalty number 20.
Two minutes for slashing.
It was under-- way
under his glove.
He reached in and
grabbed the pat.
Senators power play.
21 and 1/2% on the year.
Tkachuk with a shot and
a save by Gustavsson.
And these teams will put a point
in the bank and go to overtime.
Stay behind.
I'm going to go for BOA.
Right up, right up.
Yeah, boys.
Almost.
Fans here in Stockholm seen
a little bit of everything.
And now they're going
to see a shootout.
Shoots, and Gustavsson
makes a save.
And he's stopped by Forsberg.
Go, boys.
Shooting next for Ottawa,
number nine, Josh Norris.
Here comes Norris for Ottawa.
Norris scores!
Eriksson Ek must score
to keep the Wild alive.
A Forsberg save wins
it for the Senators.
Swede against Swede.
Moves in, goes backhand,
tries to force.
It doesn't work, and Ottawa
wins it in the shoot out.
And the Senators win
both games in Stockholm.
Woo!
That's it, fellas.
Fellas, I'll let you
guys have the room.
Hell of a job tonight
by a lot of guys.
Obviously, the Swedes
brought her to the table.
Great ball.
Outstanding.
Brandy, great ball, but I
got to give it to my boy.
We came here for
another four points,
and it all ended up
working out for us.
Forsberg, you know,
got to come back,
ended up playing an awesome
game tonight to help us win.
Great game, boys.
Let's go party now.
Something big is coming.
Shoot puck!
W are coming every time, boys.
We know it.
Holy Mackinaw.
Something big is coming.
Final game of the 2023
NHL global series.
Avicii Arena, another
sold out crowd here
in beautiful Stockholm, Sweden.
Now please welcome the Toronto
Maple Leafs and the Minnesota
Wild.
Stockholm has been the
host of the most games
outside of North America.
Of course, Swedish
players really
making an impact in the
NHL last couple of decades.
Ceremonial puck drop
out at center ice
featuring Mats Sundin, Leafs
legend, great Swedish player.
Here we go.
I want hard C. Move, Patty.
I got wide.
No stick.
Those got no stick.
No.
Harr is off the goal
post and stayed out.
It was loose behind Fleury, but
Giordano couldn't poke it home.
While getting some puck luck.
Did Gio not put that in?
You got away with one there.
Tips free.
Rossi up top.
Merrill will shot.
He scores.
It's his first of the year, and
the Wild have taken a 1-0 lead.
Let's go
Hey, they're cheating, Woll.
You guys get them, just--
in the ozone, like, if you
guys-- if you guys kind of get
in trouble.
Here's Nylander.
A pass in, a deflection.
They score!
Auston Matthews to
tie the game at 1.
Jump.
Jump, Big ball.
Better sticks, boys.
Better sticks.
Yeah!
10, 10, 10!
10, 10!
Nice play.
Whoa!
In comes across, then
he shoots, scores!
Matthew Knies gives
Toronto the lead.
Nice play, buddy.
Lead the rush then.
What a [MUTED] pass, dude!
Here we go.
Hey, stay, stay, stay,
stay, stay, stay.
Hear it coming every time, boys.
Hey, we know it.
We know it.
Quickly to Rossi, and now
Mats Zuccarello open in front.
Kaprizov backhand, forehand.
Woll made the save
with his right pad.
Kaprizov just couldn't
lift it over the right pad
of Joseph Woll.
Hey, we're done now.
We're done, Johnny.
It's gotten awfully spicy here
at the horn ending the second.
Matthew corner
into the slot area.
Quick shot by Riley scores.
And the Maple Leafs have
their first 2 goal lead.
Keep shooting, Greene!
Shoot pucks!
Middleton high slot driving one.
He scores!
Jake Middleton.
And 6:10 into the third,
the Wild pull closer.
They're down 3 to 2.
Good job, boys.
Walking in right side.
Got past the check.
Threw them under front.
They score!
Zuccarello in front of
the net, and the Wild
have pulled even
here in Stockholm.
Yeah!
And this game will be
decided beyond regulation
as we head to overtime.
I think every game we've had
here, we've had a comeback.
Yeah.
I got D. I got Brodine.
I got the D.
Oh, look out!
Oh.
You all right?
I got hit.
You all right, Fergie?
Back to Brodine.
Into the corner.
Three Maple Leafs around him.
Eriksson Ek to a
loose puck in front.
Turned and shot one.
Woll made the save.
Rebound snapped up.
Brodine will hurry
one that's blocked.
Johansson charges way,
got past the check.
He's got Brodine in front.
Johansen with a wrister.
Blocked by the
sliding Morgan Rielly.
Picked up by Nylander.
David Taveras, William Nylander.
And Johansen defending.
In comes Nylander.
Tries and scores.
William Nylander puts
an explamation point
on a brilliant
week in Stockholm.
Holy Mackinaw, Willie!
Have a trip to Sweden.
The Leafs win it in overtime.
Hey, guys.
Way to go, everyone.
It's fair to say it's
a pretty fitting end
to the whole winter.
Hell of a job, Willie.
Could you have written
a more storybook ending
for your two games over here?
I mean, it was pretty
special, for sure,
to get that OT winner there.
Just playing the games
and being with my family
and showing the guys.
Those three things were special.
Had a lot of fun.
City was great.
Atmosphere was great.
You know, I think it was just a
cool kind of little experience
that you got to enjoy
with your teammates.
4 points on this trip, OK?
Four important points.
Find ways to get the job done.
That feels good going home.
Bert, hang that thing out.
Get out of here.
Great stuff, boys.
Small, Tone, PK [MUTED]
great job tonight.
But this guy runs
this city, man.
Go home and [MUTED]
keep this thing going.
That's so much fun,
you know, getting
to play in a different barn,
and it's a pretty fun atmosphere
when you can, you
know, bring four teams
to an event like this.
I think it's special
for everybody.
The museums, the culture, the
atmosphere, and the city-- it's
such a beautiful city, and
the people are so welcoming.
Raymond in with a shot.
He scores!
A good experience for him.
It's one of the big
reasons we're here--
to build the game a little bit.
And just good players are
going to be a big part of what
we're doing going forward.
It's been awesome.
I mean, the whole
week has been great.
So, yeah.
We've been playing
good hockey too.
So, it's a good trip.
A lot of great memories
in the process.
A lot of great memories.
You know, Forsberg,
Brannström, guys
like that who got to come
back, family friends,
play in front of them.
Very cool experience for
all these Swedish guys that
come here and be
able to play in front
of their family and friends.
The connection with
Sweden and Swedes
is strong with the Maple Leafs.
That gives you a
sense of perspective,
of folks like Salming and
Sundin and those that have
come before our current crop.
It had a lot of people,
friends, family at the games.
I mean, my grandma that
hasn't seen me play
live before, I think some
of my aunts and uncles
that haven't seen
me play their live.
Was lots of fun to
have him out there.
Just enjoy the time that
we had before I headed
home I think was very
special, and that's
something I'll remember.